je vous parle maintenant du directeur
scientifique de l'institut québécois
d'intelligence artificielle yoshua
bengio et deux autres chercheurs qui
vont recevoir le prix au touring en juin
prochain
une récompense qui vient avec une bourse
de 1 million de dollars c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'équivalent du prix nobel
d'informatique on le joue alors qu'il se
trouve à san francisco bonjour monsieur
urbain jo
bonjour bon alors félicitations d'abord
pour ce prix merci vous vous y attendiez
ben disons que j'étais quand même
surpris parce que c'est extrêmement
compétitif et c'est un domaine qui a été
un peu dans l'ombre de l'intelligentsia
de l'informatique et donc recevoir ce
prix c'était une reconnaissance pour non
seulement le travail qu'on a fait mais
aussi toute cette direction de recherche
que nos collaborateurs et nous ont
exploré pendant les dernières décennies
bon alors ça représente pour vous est
passé mais une reconnaissance du travail
qui a été fait est ce qu on vient pour
ainsi dire aussi confirmé le fait qu'il
faut continuer à travailler pour
approfondir l'intelligence artificielle
tout à fait on est encore très loin de
machines aussi intelligente que l'humain
et je dirais même qu elles sont plutôt
stupide aujourd'hui même si leur niveau
d'intelligence est déjà suffisant pour
avoir un impact économique très
important pour aider dans le domaine de
la santé par exemple à reconnaître des
cellules cancéreuses pour être
finalement l'argent derrière les
systèmes de voitures qui se conduisent
toute seules ce soit pour la traduction
automatique sur votre téléphone ou les
engins de recherche
c'est déjà dans beaucoup d'endroits
autour de vous mais ça va être amené à
se retrouver encore dans beaucoup plus
de choses d'industrie de ce secteur dans
les années qui s'en viennent pour dire
que vous vous étiez en tête et a
travaillé dans ce domaine là autant avec
l'ontarien joeffrey une tonne comme
français yann le cas avec lesquels vous
partager ce prix là ce que vous leur
avez parlé depuis que la nouvelle est
sortie
bien sûr bien sûr on s'est parlé on
échange et on est on est des amis tous
les trois donc on est on est assez
proches et on vit ça avec beaucoup
d'émotion effectivement bon lorsque vous
vous parler maintenant est ce que vous
vous dites ou est ce qu'on s'en va
partir d'aujourd'hui toujours vous savez
c'est le travail de chercheurs de se
poser la question qu'est ce qui s'en
vient c'est quoi les grandes questions
c'est quoi les
c'est quoi qui fonctionne pas puisque on
voudrait améliorer donc il ya encore des
grands défis devant nous chaque
chercheur évidemment explore une voie
différente
puis c'est important parce que la
recherche une exploration c'est une
découverte on sait pas d'avancé qu'on va
trouver c'est grâce au financement des
gouvernements comme gouvernement du
canada le gouvernement du québec qui ont
permis d'explorer des pistes qui était à
l'époque pas nécessairement à la mode
qu'on est rendus là où on est
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on peut en déduire que le fait
de travailler chacun de votre côté mais
en partageant vos informations par
n'ayant un but commun ça a permis de
faire avancer plus vite vos recherches
oui parce que la science est une
histoire qui n'est pas individuel mais
qui est communautaire c'est parce qu'on
avait le soutien les uns des autres
parce qu'on ait changé nos informations
on a aussi publié quelques articles
ensemble mais beaucoup on a travaillé
avec nos laboratoires en en
communication proches les uns des autres
et ça ça fait partie de la culture dans
beaucoup de communautés scientifiques
qui fait que c'est agréable aussi de
faire de la recherche
bons caf quand on fait une bourse de 20
millions $ c'est une bonne question
moi j'aimerais probablement tu dis si
cet argent pour des causes
environnementales en trop je n'ai pas
encore réfléchi complètement la question
bon alors et puis le prix qui sera remis
au mois de juin ce sera l'occasion en
votes pour retrouver justement vos deux
collègues les deux autres mavericks
comme les appelle retrouver tous les
trois oui bon est ce que vous allez vous
êtes du genre à vous asseoir à une table
et à élaborer des projets pas vous dire
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
mais à partir de maintenant tu te fais
quand on se rencontre on échange nos
idées on peut critiquer aussi mais de
manière respectueuse et puis c'est ce
qui fait avancer le débat qui comme ça
qu'on progresse
bon depuis le temps que vous travailler
là dessus il ya de plus en plus de gens
finalement qui qui ça colle à vos
recherches qui travaillent avec vous
j'ai l'impression que ça peut aussi
peut-être aider des gens à collaborer à
vos recherches vous vois venir vous
trouver pour voir si j'ai une idée en
matière d'intelligence artificielle ce
qu'on pourrait aussi travailler là
dessus
oui faire beaucoup de gens qui me
contacte avec leurs idées puis beaucoup
de jeunes surtout qui se lancent dans ce
domaine là et ça c'est très important
parce qu'on va avoir besoin de ces
jeunes là pour l'économie du futur qui
veuille qui va tirer parti de ces
nouvelles technologies et donc aux mille
à l'institut que dont je suis directeur
scientifique et que j'ai fondées on a
une grande partie notre mission qui est
aidé à former les gens à tous les
niveaux évidemment les étudiants au
doctorat maîtrise mais aussi des gens à
l'extérieur du milieu universitaire qui
veulent apprendre plus peut-être
contribuer au développement
entreprenariale ou des ingénieurs etc
la belgique ou encore une fois
félicitations et bon séjour à san
francisco au revoir merci au revoir